es gibt ja schon wieder corinna zoff in
der bundesregierung können wir jetzt
endlich mit corinna normal leben oder
läuft die ganze maßnahme maschinerie
schon wieder an der karl lauterbach der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat ja schon
wieder für die masken pflicht den
innenräumen plädiert hierbei bild live
im herbst könne er sich das wieder
vorstellen so waren seine worte und
jetzt spricht er im hintergrund schon
längst wieder über härtere maßnahmen vor
allen dingen mit den grünen mit dem
grünen ministerpräsidenten zum beispiel
erfordert heute kretschmann lauterbach
dazu auf er sagt er will die ganze
palette wieder haben auch die
möglichkeit ausgangssperre zu verhängen
und dabei hat man sich im vordergrund
eigentlich darauf geeinigt erst mal
alles so zu belassen die fdp ist
entsprechend wütend zoff in der
koalition hier in berlin und vor allen
dingen einer ist wütend und hier bei uns
im studio bei bild live wolfgang kubicki
herzlich willkommen herzlich willkommen
einen wunderschönen guten morgen was
macht sie besonders wütend im moment die
diskussion die ja völlig unzeitgemäße
sind das infektionsschutzgesetz geht bis
zum 23 september wir haben ausreichend
zeit nach der evolution der maßnahmen
uns zu unterhalten ein normales
verfahren durchzuführen und ich will mal
darauf hinweisen herrn kretschmann
anderen muss man mal wieder sagen
gesetzgeber ist der deutsche bundestag
im deutschen bundestag brauchen eine
mehrheit man braucht eine
koalitionsmehrheit und gibt es nur mit
der fdp und nicht gegen die fdp das
heißt wir wird sie fdp sich dann
positionieren wird sie anfangs noch laut
schimpfen und dann am ende vielleicht
auch wieder mitmachen ich weiß doch
wieder mitmachen wir sehen ja dass die
maßnahmen die wir im april beschlossen
haben gewirkt haben wir können heute
ohne masken durch die gegend laufen wir
haben zwei instanzen aber ich will daran
erinnern dass wir die höchsten instanzen
300.000 pro tag hatten im märz da
bestand masken pflicht aller ordnen um
das dort vielleicht darauf hin dass die
masten pflicht so wirksam nicht ist ich
empfehle masken tragen für diejenigen
die sich sorgen machen weil es ein guter
eigenschutz ist aber wir dafür eine
pflicht brauchen die jeweils in den
schulen auf keinen fall nachdem wir
wissen welche katastrophalen folgen das
für die kinder hat schauen wir erstmal
anlass der sachverständigenrat am 13
juni abliefert und dann schauen wir uns
einmal an worauf wir uns einstellen
müssen also ich warne immer vor solchen
panik maßnahmen dass wir jetzt über
ausgangssperren reden da kretschmann ist
einfach nur irre die frage ist halt von
patrizier gewesen ob sie das dann am
ende mitmachen also ob sie jetzt poltern
und im herbst dann wenn der
sachverständigenrat irgendwas anderes
sagt umfallen oder gibt es rote linien
also können sie uns jetzt sagen dass zum
beispiel lockdown zum beispiel
allgemeine masken pflicht machen wie ihr
macht die fdp auf keinen fall mit ich
kann sicher sagen dass wir keinen
allgemeinen lockdown mitmachen werden
und ich kann hier sicher sagen dass es
masken pflicht den schulen nicht geben
wird das werden wir nicht zulassen wir
wissen dass die nebenfolgen
katastrophaler waren als die wirksamkeit
der masken wir werden eine vielzahl von
empfehlungen aussperren aber alles was
vernünftiges werden wir tun
ausgangssperre ausgangssperre hat sich
nicht nicht bewährt ist auch wir werden
da sagte kretschmann heute
meine der kann ja ganz zu hause bleiben
aber dass nach 22 uhr das virus
gefährlicher wird als vor 22 uhr halte
ich eher für für eine falsche
einschätzung das wird es nicht geben
definitiv nicht mehr bei der der lok
dann ist es der bundesweit geben wird
das verspricht sich so leichter weiß es
natürlich auch dann hintertürchen gibt
die alle die den doktor möchten dann
auch wieder nutzen wird man muss ja nur
wieder die lage wie sie auch jetzt
herbeiruft dass man gewisse hotspots hat
und schon gibts halt in gewissen
hotspots wieder ein laptop oder gegen
gewissen hotspots wieder
schulschließungen davor ja das ist ja
das ist ja das mache ich mal wieder
hinweise dass die ministerpräsidenten
die gesundheitsminister die jetzt laut
schreien so auch mal ins gesetz gucken
können sie haben bis zum 23
alle möglichkeiten beispielsweise über
einen hotspot regung wenn sie das selbst
feststellen ihrem land für bestimmte
maßnahmen sorge zu tragen deshalb
braucht man bis zum 23 09 keine weiteren
verschärfungen angesichts der
entwicklung der virus lage die wir jetzt
sehen mikron und einer variante die
vielleicht infektiöse aber weniger
gefährlich ist stellen sich die fragen
nach geweihten weit gehen und
einschränkende maßnahmen nicht mehr und
der bundestag ist wirklich in der lage
innerhalb von 48 stunden wenn es drauf
ankommen sollte eine regelung zu
schaffen aber erst wenn es drauf
ankommen sollte also die
ministerpräsidenten sich daran gewöhnt
haben jeden dienstag im fernsehen zu
erscheinen weil sie die maßnahmen
verkünden können diese plattform wieder
zu geben das ist nicht aufgabe der
freien demokraten